great everyone I'm Ilana and today I'm
reading me in comments because I hate
myself but seriously this is oddly
popularly requested video so I had a
friend scour the internet and found some
new things humans said about me and now
I'm going to read them feel sick
enjoyment thumbnails suck does anyone
else think she probably smells really
bad I go to the gym every generally what
we should say I was honestly so
disappointed when I found out she didn't
buy a switch like I thought she actually
cared about Dame's and now I know she's
just another Nintendo hata sony fanboys
shill at IGN I don't go to the site
anymore at all you can buy me one if you
want that'd be cool I wouldn't say no
that dude your nostrils are so small how
you even breathe Oh may I get a nose job
maybe Allah is so napot but she has
mostly guy friends and tattoos and that
doesn't [ __ ] staff what is what is that
thousand [ __ ] stare alright
Allah has a pretty perfect face but it
looks like she has a slag Lee boyish
body tbh she's never even played halo
alright this is clearly the most
offensive one on the list this is a
neighbor funny say to my face you're
[ __ ] stupid if you think anyone would
date you hideous Grambling woman I don't
know we're talking about you right like
a 16 year old who hasn't hit puberty
does anyone else think Alana's eyelashes
look like tiny spiders because it's
seriously freaking me out
I only sub to you because a Friendly AI
where the heck is him I don't know a
Friendly AI I think he made a video
about me once if you subscribe to me
because you expected to see him in my
videos you should definitely leave I
wouldn't even [ __ ] her with a box full
holding your YouTube is a lazy and
complain too much shut up you have a
really strange channel no info woof
sorry maybe go get a real job maybe
something you can appreciate maybe
cooking hambo
you know but airheads I studied
journalism for four years sorry if it's
racist but it's true it sums up to a
great start
Australians are all rapists criminals
and we do not want you in the u.s. Trump
will get rid of your visa as soon and I
can't wait for you to be gone
honestly well this is a lot to digest
but the good news is trillions on a rate
so your excellent comment is not racist
why I hate you because you are not human
somebody get this horrible show ah
you're not hipster you're just dirty
he's right though they only put a lot on
podcast to get views seriously how dumb
do you think we are not to know that
people say this all the time but they
don't put me in the thumbnails podcast
so how would it get views I don't get it
doesn't make sense she sounds confused
like do I want to speak in an Australian
accent or an American one and she's like
stuck in between and it's annoying me so
much I thought I don't have any control
over the way that I found I caught WTF
the girl is blank nothing to do in no
man's sky come on why do so many people
hate on this game I think jealousy in
some kind - you haters go play goat
simulator well he definitely told me so
Alana Pierce and left immediately no
thanks
surprise the boyfriend is so attractive
honestly she seems like she's spoiled so
I always assumed she'd just be a boring
starfish in bed but maybe he's interests
what all right
this is ridiculous and actually
surprisingly fun alrighty I have to
thank some of my mega Charizard on
patreon
they are Raja Duggan Eric Allen Scott
Dixon Demetrios and Michael Yost
thank you guys so much for your support
and to everyone else I hope you enjoyed
this video I will see you guys next time
bye